people really like think I'm gonna walk
into an interview with like a margarita
in one hand I like a penis in the other
but I'm actually pretty too I'm busy I'm
writing I'm working like that's good I
don't have time for all those drinks and
dicks I'll never be sitting here again
Amy Schumer
welcome to Fandango frontrunners oh my
god let's take stock of the last couple
months of your life shall we let's do it
the movie that you wrote and star in
became a gargantuan hit over the summer
is there a moment that's happened the
last six months that stands out a moment
that really stands out was hosting SNL
which is such a big deal for me just
growing up loving that show and then all
my friend you know from New York so all
my friends and my family or everybody
was there and when I was done and waving
and walking back and I got to have a
glass of wine with my sister in the
greenroom and it's just the best we were
just looking at each other like wow so
obviously this is a film that is
partially autobiographical right do you
feel like the process of writing it and
filming it helped you through issues
that you've dealt with in your life um
no I am still repeating all of my
patterns promise I it really was a time
of major self-reflection and that was a
huge step for me and I wouldn't say that
I've overcome all those obstacles but it
was kind of therapeutic and it was it
was I learned a lot
I love the bond that you share with your
sister as we do see in the movie has
there been an experience where you ever
doubted that you could get to where you
wanted to be in your career that she
helped you through no that's a shame
that she couldn't help you out in that
way no the only reason anything that
I've ever done is happen is my sister
trainwreck there's not a sentence in
that script that she didn't have a
saying she was my what's it called when
you don't need someone around
oh yeah she keeps me alive and yes I
better be nicer does she run around
taking all the credit for everything
that's happening no she doesn't she she
lets me of all the credit and you know
what I say let's keep it that way well
your sisters influence is all over this
movie especially in this scene with you
and brie Larson you play sisters in the
movie
your father has recently passed you've
had some rough moments and this is kind
of the two of you trying to come
together in see eye to eye so we'll
watch them we'll talk about some of the
moments okay I want you to know that I
act like everything you do in your life
is so wrong it's stupid but it's just
because I I don't think that I can have
that okay scale of one to ten how scary
was it to do a scene like this because
this is not your default setting to be
this emotional I feel like I'm not
afraid of emotion I've been doing
theater my whole life pretty much and
you know more people know me as a comic
the scary thing was to be being this
vulnerable and III wouldn't let my own
sister be on set the days that I had
emotional scenes with break because it
was just too much to think about her
watching it know she'd be worried about
me and I'd be worried about her that's
what made it hard I wasn't afraid I
wasn't gonna do a good job I knew I was
gonna just imagine having that
conversation with my own sister and just
being that honest with myself it was
really hard what you're seeing on camera
is me actually experiencing it okay
here's the rest of the scene I know what
I am I Know Who I am and I'm broken can
you tell me what inspired that line I'm
broken is it easy to encapsulate is it
easy to encapsulate me being broken no
David's nothing um yeah I mean just the
feeling of things
you're okay and everything's fine and
your defense mechanisms that have gotten
you where you are and carried you along
this whole time in a certain age I feel
like they start to to bite you in the
ass and just when you realize like oh
I've done irreparable damage to my
myself and my self-esteem and you feel
broken
what did close friends and family
members say to you when they saw this
film it was less about the performance
and just they were proud of me and they
liked it and I think they were excited
for other people to get to see that that
side of me so when I interviewed you
over the summer I said you're going to
the Golden Globes this year I mean duh I
remember you saying that and you're
gonna guys hi yeah hello do you still
feel that way don't think so well I
still don't really understand what get
someone to the Golden Globes
I know I've always watched them right
and it looks fun okay but getting to go
to these award shows and getting to hold
a statue next to Meryl Streep and like
my favorite actors and directors that
you know them being nice enough to speak
to me as I mean they're pretending I'm
an equal but just just to be standing up
there with them and feel like I I I have
a place in this business and then I'm
gonna do my best to stay to stay here
well I'm super excited for you I'm
really glad that you were able to join
us today so thank you so much thanks for
having me if you have not seen
trainwreck be sure to check it out and
thank you so much to the TCL Chinese
Theatre imax for having us today and
thank you for watching fandango
frontrunners